hola cómo están los dos
podía escucharlos a todos hablar estaba
como
estoy más emocionada que nerviosa estás
lista para comenzar estoy de acuerdo sí
[Música]
uno detrás del otro sigue en el orden
hola
muy bien
bien
estoy aterrada hola gracias por venir
gracias por salir chicos
estas listas y estoy lista
[Música]
sí
e
[Música]
cuando iba caminando hacia ella hizo un
leve giro a la derecha entonces pensé
genial voy a entrar bien y luego hizo un
giro a la izquierda y me rompió el
corazón
[Música]
no tuvo ninguna duda no hubo tiempo para
interactuar fue como sal de aquí pero
ops está bien sabes no sería la primera
vez
me escogió sí qué bien que se siente y
se siente bien eso creo
[Música]
y
lo siguiente
[Música]
ella sonrió pero luego no me seleccionó
no me hizo sentir bien pero ya sabes ya
me lo han hecho antes entender así que
es casi lo mismo no es tan malo
me siento más
como
si tuvieran que seleccionar no me gusta
ella se pueden ir
no hay problema está bien no me siento
mal
no tendría nada que hablar con ella la
verdad no me sentía atraído para nada
me siento bien creo que la parte más
difícil ya pasó había algunos chicos
lindos ahí estoy emocionada hola hola
meredith jason mere dimick mucho gusto
mucho gusto ni cómo te llamas chico
número 3 checo número 3 o vaya soy la
elegida con mucho gusto ryan meredith
mejora mucho tu estilo gracias acerté
también y como te da un poco nerviosos y
mágico díaz encantado de conocerte
encantada me gustan tus link gracias
cuéntame algo sobre ti
estoy nervioso el que se quede en blanco
en lo único que pienso es en embarazados
es extraño cierto esto es extraño
me gusta mucho tu cabello
gracias de hecho esa es una de mis
inseguridades
estaba confiado probablemente me va a
elegir
pienso que si buena para hablar con las
personas sí
que le agradece a las personas esto es
por mi voluntad propia por eso estoy muy
emocionado de estar aquí que quieres
decir por mi voluntad propia alguien te
obligó a venir aquí bien estudio en la
lm un estudio en la uci asombroso estoy
tomando una clase de lingüística serie
haces análisis sintáctico si eso si
vendo mi compañía inversionistas en wall
street lo gracioso es que hago a hombres
blancos calvos y ricos más ricos nuestra
función
de que son estatuas los puedes leer si
quieres un modelo independiente con
vídeos en youtube si soy pasante de
analista que se sentó tiempo lee me
gusta leer oa mí también trato sólo unos
que dos minutos que te gusta hacer me
gusta ver el fútbol te gusta el realismo
es mi equipo favorito escalar y
bicicleta trabajo en microsoft como
ingeniero de software vaya solo mejor
que mi pasantía has estado en el área de
manhattan beach este comando no
realmente no hay lugar favorito quieres
ir a la playa si podemos ir algún mayor
soy más fanática del norte de california
también soy una chica fanática siguiente
fantástico abrazarlo algún problema si
nos podemos dar un abrazo fue un placer
conocerte gusto en conocerte
gracias gusto en conocer en conocerte
ya tomaste una decisión definitiva si ya
tomé una decisión porque pienso que es
súper lindo y
me gustan sus ojos además fue agradable
hablar con él o cielos
o ya viene hola me alegra volver a
habitación bueno
si te escoge a ti fuiste el que más me
agradó y
creo que eres súper lindo de hecho me
gustan mucho tus ojos pro sí sí me
pareció que fue fácil conversar contigo
y creo que nos podríamos llevar bien eso
es prácticamente todo no sé si te
gustaría hacer planes me gusta la idea
digo puedes tener mi número hagámoslo
aquí anota tu contacto pienso que es muy
atractiva me alegra salir con ella y ver
si de verdad hay algo ahí estoy feliz de
haber hecho esto conocí a alguien genial
tal vez se convierte en algo es bueno
tener una persona nueva con quién salir
todos los chicos con los que hablé eran
fantásticos creo que en general todos
eran buenos chicos y me sentí muy
afortunada de tener la oportunidad de
conocerlos cómo estuvo la cita
estuvo bien pero creo que no nos
conectamos está buscando algo diferente
yo busco algo diferente tu corazón se
detiene cuando caminas hacia alguien así
y sabes que va a juzgarte sólo por tu
apariencia es hermosa tiene unos ojos
azules penetrantes lo que es
hipnotizante tal vez vaya a la lm un día
solo para pasar el rato y ver qué pasa
tres dos uno
muy bien
3 2 1
[Risas]
[Música]